hi everyone this is unit Viacom are
bringing you the highlights from the
world blitz championship after scoring a
massive seven and a half out of nine
points on the last day Magnus Carlsen
has won the championship for the second
year running the key to scoring this
many points in such a strong tournament
is going aggressive being able to win
with both white and black eye I want to
look at this game where among how played
the white pieces and see how Magnus
managed to get the initiative and really
put pressure on his opponents with the
black pieces when how played be for a
good move because now you put pressure
towards the black pawn as it turns out
Magnus wasn't really interested in that
pond
he plays nightly sakes and when white
takes it he doesn't take back he doesn't
care about this pawn he wants to go for
an attack he goes f5 takes takes and now
this black pawn on the side you cannot
really take that one because if white
takes there is the very scary thread of
this pawn trapping the white bishop so
you need to give the bishop an escape
square
pungho played Queen e1 Magnus castled
and after rook b1 we have an interesting
position black has gambit 'add a pawn
but that was not the end of the story
Magnus go see for opening up for his
bishop and when Wang Hao takes this one
Magnus goes f4 it's a spectacular
sacrifice objectively the computer is
not really a fan however this is blitz
chess you have three minutes a lot of
mistakes do get made and fortune favors
the bold and this was definitely
old play from magnus carlsen and he
managed to win himself a world
championship title wouldn't it